[Musique]
bonsoir mes chers petits amis je ne sais
pas ce qui se passe mais j'ai
l'impression que gros ours prépare
quelque chose de bizarre qu'est ce que
tu caches derrière ton dos de beaux
ballons de toutes les couleurs
mais enfin gros source
tu vas te faire mal ne fait pas ça
surtout je t'en prie mon grand-père
voyageait en ballon je peux bien faire
comme lui
pop là nous nous fais attention les
poubelles
on you lie modo aux bonus des top et je
suis descendu en ballon oui mais alors
pourquoi faire pour faire comme mon
grand-père dans le temps on voyageait
toujours en ballon peut-être qu'il
faudrait mettre un moteur assez ballon
sûrement la prochaine fois je mettrais
un moteur ont donc voilà il y en a quand
même un pour mirabel et impôts pour
petit louis
c'est chic aussi on va voyager emballant
oui mais seulement pour jouer à lille
qui joue avec nous mais non sans voyage
un ballot toi tu montes sur la table tu
sors ou la non moi les ballons c'est
fini pour lui n'ont même pas pour jouer
non houle lol lol hommes et voilà on pas
emballant ou le haut
oh oh oh toi et ont arrêté les enfants
j'ai mal au coeur en ballon voila voila
merci patron tu as déjà tu viennes non
demain on part en voyage mais dans une
semaine on sera de retour
on reviendra vite par des rebelles ma
foi non on part sur une fusée on va dans
la lune
enfin il en a de la chance je les vois
d'autres enfin nous allons faire un
voyage d'étude
un voyage scientifique
10 les belles la lune
[Musique]
tiens
qu'as tu lui donneras ces jolies fleurs
de la part de petits loups et l mirabel
merci les enfants
je n'oublierai pas maintenant aller vite
au dodo
tu sais on serait très sage plus cadré
sol c'est promis c'est bien les enfants
je pars tranquille au revoir à bientôt
valley news revoir lice fait un beau
voyage dans la lune
à bientôt
[Musique]
mais bien sûr
à très bientôt mes petits amis soyez
tout ça encore plus gentil que p'tit
louis et mirabel pendant notre absence
je compte sur vous et allez chaque soir
sagement vous coucher comme d'habitude
aux halles en hausse il faut partir
nous allons ranger notre nuage au garage
et vérifier notre fusée revault aux
ordres pas trop au revoir tous nos
petits et grands amis à bientôt
bonne nuit bonne nuit
[Musique]
oh